hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to knock no whoa Wow
hey that's a problem that's kind of an
issue man um a not seeing this use your
telescope to look outside oh the guests
almost never kill they only bring you
back because you haven't finished yet
okay you're talking about how when they
find me Oh someone is staring at me from
outside constantly what do you want what
is there something wrong with me maybe
maybe you're talking about the gigantic
giant that's staring from outside you
tell you about that guy big guy kind of
big he's big the horns I can see you
where are you are you talking to man who
are you talking to so anyway that's how
you gonna oh he lost me when I was very
level and then he lost his mind he
stopped seeing me who I heard footsteps
in the house someone closed the door
maybe I should check the entrance just
one more time to make sure it's locked
tight you telling me to actually do that
cuz I'll do it I'll do whatever you say
man just don't murder me here
is it locked right the first time what
first time we learned about the program
was in the fall about six months after
the unrest they described it as a
community initiative most of the tenants
gathered in the courtyard of her complex
no one knew what was going on everyone
was shouting worried and guessing what
will come next all kinds of rumors it
came down what were the pages just
waiting at the front door they would be
removing children as if from unfit
parents for what purpose who knew but
against a backdrop of everything our
government had done and justified in the
recent years the outlook was most
sinister at point I decided to grab my
son and escape the city to the middle of
nowhere
first news about the program first to
summon arises arrives and they announce
a gathering usually at a school then the
doorknockers come young bastards like
volunteers wearing some party insignia
they go through the complex with lists
and check who shows up and who doesn't
I'm not the only one - getting clever
everyone is getting ready to leave for
somewhere we've already been given
another families furniture to look after
everything is changing parents are
hiding their kids with other people so
now we have two more I don't leave my
child's side for even a minute even in
my sleep I hold his head the other
children's sleep with us - it's crowded
the world is falling apart seems to me
this situation is added for civil war I
had a nightmare that our turn came we
were led to the school shoved into what
used to be the gym my son and I sat in a
cell with a small barred window I tried
to push him through the opening from the
other side came shouts that any kid they
catch would be taken unconditionally
there is no suffering worse than this
feeling of helplessness it's past the
time when I should leave this apartment
but concern for the children stops me
stumbling around like a sleepwalker I
don't recognize this thing they took the
little ones I haven't seen them for at
least two days I suddenly found another
child in the corner whose is it no one
knows it sits in the corner wrapped up
in a blanket doesn't show his face
doesn't say a word sometimes I think it
may be a girl I won't drink anymore all
I can think about is my little invisible
one doesn't either speak I'm not
pressing don't even want to watch let it
keep playing hiding
seek the child is like closed in the nut
with nothing inside doesn't take food
but all those kids they forage for
themselves somehow little by little
they've learned to look after themselves
most likely all I need to do now is just
love her and eventually she'll show
herself maybe it's a boy after all it
started to make little noises from
inside his blanket cocoon odd squeaks
and croaks it still turns away but at
least now it's reacting to me it seems
like it really is it's really invisible
it tries to reach out and touch me from
time to time but there are no hands
there only emptiness
maybe she escaped from the program is
that what they're doing to alert our
kids I shouldn't be thinking about it I
don't want to found the bedding on the
invisible bed the crumpled and tossed as
if in disgust I gently asked why it only
creaked out something about how the bed
smells bad it took it out for a walk I
took it out for a walk it's a dry autumn
lots of sense in the air we picked
berries and leaves and I asked what
smells he liked silence it accepts
nothing and then it lets me know that it
wants to get something to show me I let
it go the city is almost deserted now
why not let it run around for a bit
there is no child in the house but on
the bed I found what it brought back for
me strong selection a few shriveled
maple leaves all mixed up with wet dirt
as if scooped them up from the ground
and cupped hands and carried them home
folded in its clothes now all these rags
have been washed have to be washed
whether I want to or not I'll have to
see Woodsen's hidden hidden inside but I
think I can already guess we became
strangely close in the weeks that we
spent together
okay that's all of them wow I guess I
was supposed to find those before what
huh nope okay I'm gonna ring the bell it
is if if the measurements aren't lying
then these are not hallucinations these
footprints are real and they're not mine
but who can know sure sure after all
this equipment is old if you say so man
but then again you say a lot of things
that I don't particularly agree with
your broom from room come out what okay
so apparently according to those notes
there was some child a testing program
for some experimentation
Nazz going on that the whole government
was behind and wasn't good probably was
not good probably wasn't any good just
gonna say that right now probably was no
good oh hang on wait let me where's her
news in that room there was a new stair
oh hi stop opening and closing my door
if you would please would you kindly not
do that I see something peeking over the
ridge over there it's not here either
what's out here what not what is not
here stop bang bang banging all right
seriously why is there a noose in this
room I've never seen this room before in
my life I don't know every every life is
given only so much time when you look at
the clock you think about how long you
have left it's the best to chase these
thoughts away once you think of
something terrible it can come true if
you say so door open yep okay let's go
outside I guess that's a great idea
great idea well I guess alright so I
found out a lot more about the backstory
so this kid has been living alone I
don't know if he's still kid anymore or
not but I've already had this dream and
not too long ago the hour is at hand
it's time to get ready to leave okay
okay
what is that what is that what is that
now what are we looking at what am I
looking at
it's little cracks forming here see
there's a little cracks forming around
the edges of my vision going on it's
getting bigger
what I don't know hey everybody I don't
know what's going on I need to find this
girl wait I see something
was that Oh was that the box head Dyer
all that far back oh no that encroached
the darkness that probably wasn't a good
thing uh-uh little girl little girl wait
huh another box head okay don't don't
run into the box heads shouldn't running
that's not a good little girl need to
find the little girl before it's too
late
it's almost too late you're not you're
not a little girl you you aren't either
a box head bastard
shut up box it you dumb bastard get out
here yeah yeah yeah okay so there are
box heads and Levey things all over the
place and my vision is not doing so well
and I get a weird crack at the top of my
bar uh this tea leaves things and I
don't hear any voices ah what am i doing
hello what's that is that actually a
little girl I don't think that actually
was a little girl no gotta be getting
closer come on
the hell is big where is she I found her
so easily before hey god damn it I ran
right into that horn others I'm gonna go
insane I hope this doesn't end in game
over if I do that would shock I probably
just have to loop back the same day
again oh come on
dammit I ran right in home I swear I've
got I've got this I got this headlight
are the light on my face it causes a
glare right on the right edge of my
screen so oh that's not good the blood
shot in my vision is turned I dodged
those guys the blood shot on my vision
is starting to turn red I still haven't
found the little girl still confused
what okay that's why it's forbidden to
leave the shelter the house one falls
prey to the madness in the woods if you
say so but Oh
Oh continue please thank you god I'm not
ready to game over yet give it GABA good
goomy
all right whatever don't tell me that
you don't ah wait hang on I have I need
to reread these I guess come on a man a
man a man oh god I'm gonna soon pass
this Cuse me I'll be back in a sec now
blood you're losing knock knock knocking
my door oh oh okay we're outside again
now we need to very carefully uh oh we
don't have the house as a landmark
anymore I'm gonna go left because then I
can see what's in front of me and I
don't run into anything we're gonna
hurry we're not gonna run into any
monsters we're not gonna do anything
that would harm us we're just gonna go
and we're gonna be fine and we're gonna
find his little girl by the sound of her
voice I learned that that you can find
her just by her singing but I got to go
until I hear her singing actual singing
not the Peggy Peggy singing or it's just
gonna be utter silence how about that
how about that that's good to know thank
you I saw that I tell you a mile away
that's her that's all girl okay
go oh say what now do what now what's
gonna and see Asher up in this [ __ ]
okay I guess good alright we did it now
we got to find the house before we go
insane can we do it no we can't maybe I
don't know I'm not very committed to
this decision but whatever it's a
possibility that we can find the house
but you know I wouldn't bank on it I'm
never gonna be able to find it because
okay oh I'm not gonna find the house in
time and I Minoans and I see you there
who's that there who said what now who
said huh speak up what I see you shrimpy
little bastard over there wait no okay
thought I saw something maybe hiding
behind the silhouette of that tree I
don't want to take any risks I found a
little girl I gotta get back home
shut up shut up I want to find my house
that's all want to go home oh I'm not
gonna be able to find home and time I'll
come on my house my house my ding-dong
damn house is my house where's the house
where's house it's a freaking house
where's the house brah where's the house
running out of time I got maybe a minute
I either got no I died here we go I see
you there I see you there dang it
come on where's the friggin house Oh
oh no you don't owe you're hiding there
didn't go get me oh come on where's ass
what the house ah
don't tell me this is how I'm beaten I'm
friggin bin because I can't find the
freaking house yeah god dammit ah this
is stupid
no no I got ass oh don't run into anyone
on the way there
Oh Shabazz hey right as it was turning
red oh I got you oh oh oh it looks like
we've entered another dream world oh
what's with the large crack at the top
of my screen yours dingo in the beta huh
whoa that's a different noise it's
coming after me in real life while I'm
sleeping and playing here I need to get
ready quickly
if you say so I have no time to waste on
games our guests anymore
anyhow they only want to keep me inside
oh I'll try to try I'll have to try
twice as hard to avoid them it's easy to
stop thinking about them so you were
playing games this whole time hey that's
effed up man okay so anyway I'm a lot of
time but thank you all so much for
watching this is getting really
interesting haha and as always I will
see you in the next video bye
okay
okay so um
seems like a game has become fully
unstable here sorry I don't know my
objective is still the same but some
abhi which were you seem to be popping
in and out probably some problem with
the optimization of the game for loading
the grass